so we talked to near a yard about
vitamins versus painkillers and I wanted
to ask you the same question what do you
think is better for entrepreneur when he
thinks about types of ideas vitamins or
painkillers it's funny I I don't really
think about it in those terms but I
guess the way I think about it is kind
of the same same way I would say the
painkiller is a much bigger deal but
even more than the painkiller I think
you want like a life-saving drug you
want something that someone really
really needs my partner Paul boo Haight
said way better to build something that
a few people love then a lot of people
sort of like right and so that's what we
look for it's something that people
really really want because those are
gonna be your initial core of passionate
users who are gonna engage with you
sufficiently to help you develop your
product and make it better if you just
have something that people kind of like
man they'll use it a couple times and
then they'll go away and if your initial
users just go away you're left with a
ghost town right I think that the
biggest challenge for startups you know
people talk about you know you're gonna
run out of money you're this and that I
think the biggest problems that most
startups have you run out of time and
part of the reason you run out of time
is because you're fighting the apathy of
the market it's not that people know
about you and don't like you it's that
no one has any idea who you are and if
you solve something that's a really deep
pain for someone they're gonna talk
about you so forget all the talk of
conversation about you know viral
marketing this kind of marketing that
kind of marketing these tactics if you
solve something really important to
someone they're gonna mention it can you
give me an example of a vitamin and a
painkiller yeah I think that you know
again it's it's this idea of it's
different things for different people
I think stripes a pretty good example of
the painkiller integrating payments into
a website is such a big pain in the butt
without something like stripe I remember
when we integrated PayPal it took days
and weeks just like they didn't even
have developer documents that you could
read in any kind of way right and it
took weeks and to get this and the VAT
and the other thing it was
was a nightmare stripes a couple lines
of code and you have payment setup and
you know for for some people if you're
not building a website that seems like a
vitamin it seems like a nice to have but
in terms of support ability and
deployment like all these things and
ease of use that's a huge painkiller for
any when building something for
e-commerce honestly very cool
in terms of vitamins I don't know
there's there's kind of a lot of them
not to say and some of them are probably
really successful companies or become
successful over time but I think that
they are they don't scale quite as
quickly you know an incremental
hairdresser closer to your house right
you know five miles closer is a vitamin
right you could drive into the five
miles when it comes to software there
are a lot of things out there if you
look at the app charts you probably see
a lot of them